[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
yeah i've noticed lately everybody has a
opinion
and i you know
when i was young it wasn't that way you
know people would have maybe
i don't know six opinions you know
sometimes you meet a guy you'd have
eight opinions you go god damn that
guy's opinionated
but about six opinions that'd be about
and most of them are about food welcome
back to joke world today is monday may
30th and north macdonald just dropped
his brand new special it came out on
netflix today it's called nothing
special and it's the hour that he's been
working on leading up to the pandemic
where then he couldn't film it in front
of a crowd so he did it in one take in
his living room no audience just him
recording in his living room and then
after that after his special is his
friends dave chappelle david letterman
david spade a lot of dave's adam sandler
conan and molly shannon discussing the
special telling their favorite norm
stories and uh just reminiscing on on
norm it's a very very nice special and
this is the first ever episode of the
comedy world update the world of comedy
update um it's every week every monday
we're gonna start bringing you the news
of comedy there's so much happening
whether it be new specials coming out uh
new people going on each other's
podcasts the collaborations there in
case you miss it where people are on
tour if anyone gets punched or tackled
on stage we're gonna cover that just
with everything happening in the comedy
world the podcasting world the stand up
world any news that you need this is the
first ever news source dedicated just to
comedy so subscribe if you haven't every
monday the comedy news you need it we
we're delivering it starting now
this is the first episode so if you like
this idea comment oh yeah this is a good
idea and then we're also going to be
putting this on spotify and apple so you
can download this if you like it if you
want to listen on the go get the comedy
news on the go if you don't like this
idea then comment something constructive
like love the channel this is
still an all right idea maybe if it's
good and then i'll know that's
constructive and and good we're going to
put the topics we're discussing on the
side like the real news it's going to be
but it's stand-up news it's genius who
doesn't want a comedy news source
hit subscribe if you haven't you love
that idea but norm special is amazing
it's out right now on netflix it's funny
it's sad uh watching his friends talk
about him afterwards is pretty sad and
emotional but it's it's so normal
mcdonald's like to get one last joke in
like this and it's truly there's nothing
ever been done like this in comedy um
having a special come out after after
you've died is a pretty crazy thing to
do we gotta take a break time but when
we return todd glass
will read from his book no he's stoned
out of his [ __ ] mind
we'll be back
ricky gervais also had a netflix special
come out last week called supernature i
watched that it's very funny about an
hour long uh it's drawing a lot of
comparison to dave chappelle's last
netflix special because people are
outraged apparently about some of his
jokes about transgendered people what
about this person isn't a lady
well
his penis
her penis you [ __ ] figure that kind
of happens with these good specials
though i mean there's always some sort
of backlash but netflix is apparently
sticking by ricky gervais and dave
chappelle basically said if you don't
want to work on these projects you might
as well leave um so good for netflix for
supporting comedy and ricky gervais
doesn't really seem to care about the
criticism either similar dave chappelle
it seems like this stuff just rolls
right off their back to me there's
nothing controversial that because it's
just jokes it's nothing we don't do it's
not as bad as the [ __ ] we've said today
i i i i think you know and we're trying
to get us cancer yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
i don't know about it
i even explained what irony is at the
beginning of the [ __ ] show
and everyone there you know i don't know
i'm going to play two half a million
people no complaints they laughed at all
the things right but everyone's going to
complain about everything you know every
every single line someone is going to
complain either because they hate it
they don't they they don't get it uh
that it's coming after here's the thing
about comedy right you can i could i can
list
20 taboo subjects right everyone in the
world laughs at 19 of them and hates the
one that affects them you're delusional
if you think everyone in the world is
laughing at 19 out of 20 of your [ __ ]
well okay
andrew schultz announced his new
rebranded podcast flagrant instead of
flagrant 2 now it's just going to go as
flagrant and then they also got this new
studio it's very nice it's very elegant
looking it's like a like a real talk
show kind of everyone's on a couch and
then
schultz is in his own chair
the main the main feedback from the
internet from this people are just
saying that they want akash to have his
own chair just like the old studio that
he deserves his own chair they even got
a hashtag trending for literally every
comment from their new big reveal about
this huge expensive luxurious studio is
just about akash getting his own chair
let's start out feelings no facts should
akash have his own chair go
[Laughter]
[ __ ] bro
why are we getting so much hate like
we're not thoughtful about things
you don't think that we have multiple
[ __ ] setups you didn't think that
this ended up being the one that fits
the space the best [ __ ] the other
studio did feel a little bit more gritty
a little bit more flagrant this one
seems like super produced and stuff they
don't have mics anymore like physical
mics they just have them on the lapel
so it just feels more like it's a
hangout just watching some guys hang out
which is very which is nice and they
said that they they teased some other
setups like they have other uh couches
are gonna roll out when guests are there
or additional chairs
they address on the second episode after
the reveal that they're aware of the
hashtag to get akash's own chair but
they've thought it through and this is
the best way to do it so looks like this
is going to be the new look for flagrant
not flagrant two anymore
uh i don't know what do you guys think
do you like the studio do you like the
old studio do you care that it's not
called flagrant too i feel like i'm just
gonna keep saying flagrant too for just
out of habit
but also sometimes i just say flagrant
anyway so you know that it's really not
that big of a deal any of these changes
the studio looks great apparently it's
very expensive um i'm kind of on the
fence about it though because it does
look like so nice
that you you think it's like a real talk
show like it looks kind of corporate but
then you listen to what they're saying
and you're like all right no it's still
still the fellas being flagrant so let
me know what you guys think about the
new studio the first thing i'm like how
do you guys feel about the the studio
the first thing mark says he just starts
trashing the brooklyn studio and making
up lives what
well you know now it's different before
nobody wanted to come out to brooklyn
why is that a lie you're only people i
gotta ignore
so many text messages i get on a regular
basis i just gotta be like oh yeah about
that we'll definitely have you on
instagram
it's hard i hear recession
it's the recession
you know what [ __ ] it y'all crazy son oh
let's go y'all are [ __ ] crazy this is
how we doing the episode
the guest list is going to be the
section where we go through who was on
each other's podcast last week make sure
that you guys are up to date any
episodes that you might have
accidentally missed or really want to
listen to uh this is just a reminder of
who was on each other's shows last week
and uh this list will definitely add
it'll definitely grow to the podcast
that we cover for now i'm just gonna
start off with the five basic very
popular ones that we make edits of here
that people are just interested in when
they think of comedy podcasts that have
guests um and then comment just comment
other podcasts that you would like to
see added to this list other podcasts
that you'd like to get reminded of who's
on each other's episodes and we'll grow
it from there so just starting off this
past weekend with theo vaughn he had on
giannis pappas last week very funny
conversation between those two your
mom's house with tom sagar and christina
p they talked to wheeler walker jr it's
all insider [ __ ] [ __ ] so
you want real [ __ ] listen to wheeler you
want corporate dog [ __ ] blake shelton's
your gun
props lake joe rogan had four episodes
last week he had chris stefano on neil
brennan lex friedman and ali sadiq and
then tiger belly head on josh peck go
ahead and comment what other podcasts
you want covered on this list who else
you want reminders for and the joke
world podcast that comes out every
wednesday we interview dusty slay again
that episode is wednesday full episode
on youtube and then on spotify apple
make sure you go download that and go
listen to our conversation with dusty
slay on wednesday very funny uh comedian
he was just on whiskey ginger last week
as well that's another podcast
update for you whiskey ginger dusty slay
joke world podcast dusty sleigh now
let's get into the specials other
specials that came out very recently and
maybe not last week but other specials
to keep in mind joe list has a special
on youtube it's very funny christa
stefano has one on netflix now that's
very funny and last week a relevant
special that just came out uh besides
norm and besides ricky gervais on
netflix giannis pappas put one on
youtube as well that one is called mom
love i believe um giannis pappas is
youtube so that's it that was the first
comedy world update world of comedy i'm
not really sure what we're gonna call it
yet but i will next week every monday
get your comedy news uh the first ever
media brand dedicated strictly to stand
up and comedians and podcasts and making
sure that you guys are in the loop with
all your favorite guys all your favorite
comedians um joke world subscribe now
follow us on instagram we'll send you
free stickers if you dm us your name and
address we'll send you some free joke
world stickers and we'll see you next
monday dusty slate interview wednesday
and then some other videos whenever
those are
[Music]
you